wait a second wait a second game we got
that Ru garbage.com to talk about before
we get to the episode it's your One-Stop
shop for everything are you garbage we
got teas we got lighters we got anything
you need just these and lighters but
still and they're not real Zippos either
just zip OS that's what we're saying uh
also you get tickets to your live shows
gang coming up we have Louisville
tickets still available get those and we
have Cleveland and Columbus and we're
about to announce the second leg of the
tour sign up sign the email list get
involved baby we're having a good time
love yous welcome so another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage hey it's that little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find that if they're
going to be classy yeah those are just a
big old piece of trash I'm your host
Dave Foley coming at you on a beautiful
day we're out back here at Toody's in
the new edition baby she took the night
off said she was going to get a quiet
dinner and check out a movie okay great
I don't believe her at all I'm sure
she's getting drugs somewhere but shout
out to her my co-host is coming at you
from right next to me unamused this week
fair enough he is the CEO of Ru garbage
he's an international businessman and
he's my best pal in the whole wide world
he's got his hand on my leg right now
give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan what
up gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate you subscribe
on iTunes full video of album YouTube as
you know those numbers are
cooking and obviously the greatest
website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage check it
out gang it's a party over there yes it
is and the second greatest website of
all time currently right now in the
charge is that are you garbage.com it's
got a website get tickets over there get
some merch couple of teas it's real nice
and speaking of tease how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man
it was real [__] he left me hanging
on the Toadies time news dude
this whole thing is [__] nuts give it
up for Tebow mcgruffins Toby McDonald on
the Toby cam there he is
[Laughter]
it is straight 15 year old slumber party
what's the Conshohocken curve like right
now
also it was always Bumper to Bumper
[__] [__] he's always the same
jackknife track tractor trailer you
[__] Toby came is it hot dog night
we couldn't be more excited to have more
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guest back with us again today the
goddamn family you know him from the
stuff Island podcast they're on tour
right now but we got them here and
Toadies and Chris in this joint because
we're about to get a little [__]
banged up
uh
hot dog got caught in this threat
absolutely yeah right I mean it depends
what it is a little piece of hamburger
or something it's great it tastes good
is this like riding a bubble wave from a
beer yeah sometimes I'll just have
something like okay you should be like
it should be within close proximity to
eating the
meals
you're getting a bacon egg and cheese at
midnight
so you got you've got separate
compartments in there dude this camera
setup is nuts thank you thank you you
guys are on like I don't know 8D or some
[__] it's nuts
there's all these all he's been doing
he's been here has been asking about
cameras and blunts hey D is this IMAX is
this how they do live now I woke up with
a [__] heater of a zit and I'm like
this is gonna be it's gonna you're gonna
see the the piano you don't have a zit
dude you got makeup on right now shoot
me straight wow
did you get them in high school did you
get do you have them do you get them bad
no me neither I didn't get them I felt
bad for the kids that did and if I would
get one every once a lot greater faces I
would tear it apart yeah push yeah I got
scars from you turn that mound into a
volcano yeah I let it rip I made people
look at it really you were that kid yeah
I'll own it yeah we had a couple of
those kids no you can't touch it it'll
scar I'm like dude I'm eating over it
yes
it was history class
over here
[__] pockmark face I'm cutting you're
one of my roast beef dip [__] face I'll
skip the potato Buffet oh God how are
you boys good dude what you guys have
been on the road what's how do you do on
the road you guys sharing a room on a
road no no we're separate room money now
separate room money it took a long time
[Laughter]
dude the guy didn't take the highway he
took local roads too [__] driver
local roads you're in what are you
talking about yeah he like just dude get
on the highway take us to the location
he we were on Cobblestone and [__] this
is how crazy falling asleep
Manhattan there's no dirt roads are you
coming from Queens
okay
you took the bridge I assume dude yeah
well you have to thank God
[__] highway at like uh 1 30 or
whatever and he's ripping kid's doing
great and then we get done we get in the
car and he's just
he didn't take the left to get on the
BQE I was like oh no
[Laughter]
I'm like what happened was it me did I
do something he goes I'll tell you later
we're gonna have to Kevin and [__]
Foley let's get it out so you can have
fun he's like no I'll just tell you
later it was that merge under the
highway so we got the car he's like I
just don't like the Rudy talk
you're staring at the back of his
[__] head seat like just like yeah
today's the day like murder myself
because he took a wrong turn [__]
away making me check out stuff try a cup
of decals
yeah but I mean I had to go through hell
and what do you want to take the BQE for
you got to go all the [__] away around
Brooklyn and come in it's faster no it's
not yes and the movement's consistent go
shakes my brain up
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody we say it all the time we
get home like man that begins
unbelievable it is truly incredible oh
we did it we did it for Shane recently
and obviously dude it's like the
antithesis of him oh yeah and we were he
we kicked it over he was looking I was
like what the [__] happening he looked
like we were tricking him and he's like
I don't know what I was like oh man he
can make you feel not cool yeah yeah
it's his whole [__] Mo I know you
don't even have to look at him you just
feel like dude
I started talking he literally went oh
no
laughs
yeah
what's the matter oh Connie oh dude I
slept like [__] I woke up at like 3 A.M
couldn't get back to sleep and then I
eventually went back to sleep but I was
just listening to podcasts and then they
were infecting my dreams so it's just
I've been on a podcast for about 10
hours dude bombing bombing well I'll
leave my dream in my dreams in my dream
in my dream I was too high I was I was
on like I was on bad friends whatever
and I was too high and I was just I I
didn't know where the microphone was
that's actually what I wanted but it was
it was like a what a nightmare to me is
is probably a dream that other people
when I was trying to find these rocks A
Long Walk in a park with someone I love
yeah yeah that's [__] nightmare get
me out of here I was looking for two
racquetballs to practice with in this
like Jim gymnasium like area and every
time I found them it was next to this
dude trying to like do this little fat
Mexican kid was trying to do like a
workout like he was filming himself and
I would go to grab the balls he goes
[__] him again and he would pick up
his like camera
this might have just happened you at the
gym actually and I'm the crazy one
well I felt like I was beat this guy's
[__] you know he's playing
racquetball I was tossing racquetball
awesome and here's where the nightmare
he's just throwing it I can't throw it
all right yeah oh I can't punch in my
dreams either yeah I could have a 20
mile run in the start and by the time I
get to that guy I'm just my arm turns
into ice I had that when I was a kid but
now I swear to God I was just talking to
somebody about this last week I can I
can control them very well most of my
dreams are that I can fly and I fight
demons and I can actually fight them and
I kicked the [__] out of them really I
swear to God it used to be that I was
like it would be that I could fly and I
would get to a certain height and I
would get like that feeling in my
stomach and I would fall down and wake
up but I've been able to control it and
push myself past it now I'm zipping
around everywhere you're getting the
final boss they go to the cleaners
[__] he's running errors
and they're gonna hit the pharmacy they
close at 5 30. I better leave them
there's always like a shadowy figure in
the middle of the street and like I know
that they're bad and I fly down and I
fight them damn that's [__]
incredible dude the fly
I had a dream like that recently I was
yeah I was like lucid dreaming where I
was like oh I'm Dreaming I can do
[__] anything and then Shane came in
he was like you can't do [__] no joke
why anymore I couldn't yeah we just
power down
God damn it dude I've had dreams uh I'd
be opening for like a huge famous
comedian in like a stadium and they're
like oh my God you got this and like
come to the stage next Kevin Ryan I'm oh
I'm I couldn't be further from the stage
and I have to like run down like from
the top bro I'm next that's me and I
can't I just can't get to the stage do
your hands
sometimes I get there and there's no mic
and
that's a [__] up feeling how are
things at the house boys great how's
everything going with you yeah yeah yeah
actually yeah doing really well we had a
nice trip out west
from Seattle to Portland yeah oh that's
nice yeah I've been kind of wanting to
we do that in the car it's real nice
yeah that ride's nice yeah it is okay no
there's only like certain sections it's
just all you know [__] RVs and sure
yeah boat on trash what kind of train
did you take Amtrak okay but we wouldn't
mind doing one of those things
[Applause]
throwing my bags too yeah
throw the bag and grip and watch it yeah
we get on there's just two there's three
dudes from the 50s like where you going
boy
looks like your buddy didn't make it
if
[Laughter]
I wanted to do one of those uh
sleeper cars where you take the train
across country and see all the sites
that takes for I looked into it it's
like 17 days it's like a very very
Europe or America yeah you can do it
though there's a really good one from
like New York through Toronto and then
like up top of Canada I think it's the
Canadian Pacific it is and apparently
it's like crazy nice but it takes it's
like 28 days or something crazy who's
got to die I mean that would be nice
yeah I will find it for 17 days just to
be not have to really do anything but be
on the train
I smell a patreon goal well we have one
to take them to uh the Grand Canyon he's
never seen a great game we can do that
I've never seen the Grand Canyon oh dude
it's never seen it in person
I've seen you guys ever see a postcard
with Grand Canyon yeah and it was just
like being there my dad said I was
FaceTiming at the other day another
assault in person and what are you how
come you've been to the Grand Canyon you
say that like everybody should be there
yeah I mean at this age you should have
been there already when did you go I
don't know how do I disagree I mean like
it is a thing that a lot of people see I
went on to get out of here with that
[__] I went online
yeah no I don't remember it was like
college
I just want I want to go to like a crazy
spring break well Drexel has like three
semesters yeah our spring break because
we've never understood elderly Jewish
women in like [__] retirement homes
there's nowhere to go where there's hot
chicks you at 21 at the Grand Canyon I
imagine you looked at the Grand Canyon
for one second and then we're just
trying to [__]
yeah
I actually cried really I remember
tearing up huh and he's gonna lose all
his liquids too he's a he's a you're uh
like a a fan of the earth let's say
you're a weird dude you like ships and
stuff like that every time I'm around
you I start getting those [__] videos
I think it's just because we're on the
same Wi-Fi because oh he's autistic too
give us the videos what kind of ships
Gordon Lightfoot died this week did you
all right is that the mayor of Detroit
it's Lori life yeah Lori life you know
she looks like the new Dodger yeah the
Jeep no the new Bronco new Bronco
yeah you ever see the headlights on the
new Bronco look up uh Lori Lightfoot and
the new brother he knows who she is I
mean they don't look alike dude inserted
in Toby
Canadian singer songwriter he wrote The
Battle of the Edmund Fitzgerald yeah oh
wow 84 years old I was just listening to
him this week that's a tanker that
wrecked in the Great Lakes oh yeah so
why does this mean anything to you
because he said O'Connor like ships no
no why does this mean anything to you
like emotionally and personally I love
Gordon Lightfoot yeah a lot of great
hits Edmund Fitzgerald was a great one
sun down if you could read my mind
what's a real good brand this is nice
yeah I like you if you could read my
mind you stink
can you hear moving on
who's sang that song next please
anyway guys thanks for having us again
man yeah this place is [__] gorgeous
I know they don't get to see thank you
could you give him a tour of the whole
place we haven't yet you got it keeping
it under wraps a little it's great yeah
I got to see the rec room where you put
all the merch I sent you 400 hours worth
of [__] merch you're like are we
doing this okay man did you did you
bring a [__] lollipop to a gunfight
let me tell you something Mr C
[Applause]
what did happen to the hats
they're remade
no but what happened to the two hats
that we have we should have just brought
a hat we should have brought a hat yeah
you screwed me God damn sorry anyway
anyone bring it up
we were the Empire State Building
sure
second whiskey will really pull it in
here yeah well we did want to have we've
only drank in here uh with guests once
it was Bert we Chris in the studio with
Bert had a couple two tree pops with him
I can't pass up a time to have a be it
could be six a.m and it seems like I'm
having a beer I gotta have it of course
sure
um and then we were like we got to get
the we've been saying it for weeks we
got to get the boys in get a good
old-fashioned [__] you know
ripped yeah and then I was glad you did
clear your schedule because after this
we're going out and getting real [__]
God damn right maybe a nice din-din too
yeah I told other people not to try to
contact
I was like
yeah yeah I'm not gonna get back to it
wife asked me what I was doing I said oh
I was like uh yeah we might have a
couple of drinks on the patches like why
I was like Tommy Tommy and O'Connor are
coming over she goes oh you're a
baseball friend
what an honor yeah dude that's what it
is yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be
trouble tonight yeah you're on Christmas
already in the dark you're in a weird
mood and drinking oh yeah the first
thing I thought of when I saw the Empire
State Building was uh a week before that
but it was like before my brother went
off
[Laughter]
yeah my brother my brother was going off
to college it was like the last time we
were gonna hang out and we went to the
Empire steel building we went up to the
top and we were looking at the twin
towers and we were like ah man those
buildings [__] suck
a week later
[Laughter]
[Music]
Luke for Christ's sake yeah yeah
we're eight minutes in this guy's paying
tribute to a [__] hijackers over here
okay let's talk about this plate uh this
plate are you using like regular posters
on the wall that are all flimsy and
dog-eared and real trashy yeah you know
why because I'm a [__] idiot yeah you
are a [__] idiot but that's neither
here nor there because we're talking
about this play we're talking about
Metal we're talking about solid
beautiful posters that hang on the wall
in about two three seconds plus they
have awesome licensing deals we're
talking about Marvel we're talking about
Star Wars talking about peaky blinders
they got oh shout out to the pinky and
blind date hang one of those things up
on the wall yeah uh I'm uh Seinfeld buff
as you know I love this stuff love the
show we got a Seinfeld one hanging up
out there toady's got it mounted over
the fireplace there's also metal posters
easy to hang switch out whenever you're
ready for a change if your gamer grabs
some of the doom and World of Warcraft
or check out Star Wars as peaky blinders
as the big man said click the link in
our description to see some of our
favorites and get your ready to hang
piece of art save 22 if you buy one or
two but you get 33 off when you buy
three or more whoa whoa Why didn't it
prove this the discount will
automatically be applied to the cart
when you click our link use code Garbage
When you visit display.com and get the
discount that's display.com code garbage
or click the link in our show notes just
do it gang okay let's talk about sheath
underwear uh you mean the best thing
your dick and balls can do during the
day yeah no kidding if you got a little
guy like me it's still nice to put the
nuts in there keep them from Kate puts
in you know what I'm saying gang if you
don't like sticky balls do yourself a
favor get some sheath under where they
separate all the compartments yeah it's
like it's like a Crown Royal bag for
your Johnson it's like the cafeteria
tray when you're a little kid you don't
want your applesauce touching your pork
chops do you you're not a goddamn animal
so get some Chic underwear yeah it comes
in a ton of awesome patterns to help you
look and feel great I call them my sexy
underwear I put them on when I when I
make a move on the misses I've seen them
they're they're fantastic about a year
ago two years ago even I went through
and I replaced all my bad on these with
sheets they're fantastic I love them and
let me say this with us from Jump Street
then one of our first advertisers shout
out to Robbie I hit him up I said hey
man I'm looking for some advertising
because I got you I'll take care of you
for the ladies check out cheese sports
bras bikini briefs and boy shorts
everything's lightweight breathable and
ready for the summer heat go to
sheathunderwear.com use the code garbage
to get 20 off your first order plus
sheets underwear 100 money back
guarantee that she's underwear.com promo
code garbage get sheath underwear
support the show support your balls damn
it uh Luke can I get a PBR please uh
T-Bone's got me never mind Luke you
could also get up and get them I got
them all jammed up also know what would
happen is I would get up you'd be like
what are you leaving me and turn it on
me you're already you're locked in a
baby seat with all this [__] Tech I
know I'm all I'm in here like a goddamn
Circuit City
you got to get some of this [__]
Wireless dude oh that's guaranteed to
break yeah something Wireless [__] oh it
barely works wires yeah dude you sound
like a dad putting a stereo together
dude because it's always dude I can't
look at all these parts and I'm just
thinking the amount of adapters you
wound up finding out that you needed
while setting up whilst did I say wow
who says that I said wow okay you heard
wow
you're wrong it's wild that's what I
said okay
I Think Jesus Christ are we all this
[__] up already I'm not drunk at all
that's what the drunkest guy in the room
said that not even that [__] up
because I'm screaming at a family member
you [__] [__] you're not even drunk
dude put the turkey down Kev
oh Connor what are you talking about
what what first of all what cordless and
what adapters
what are you just saying anytime you you
set something up they tell you what
parts you need and then you wind up
going in to set it up and it's like oh
actually you need this extra thing and
then he's not wrong yeah anytime one of
you two asks me a question if Tommy asks
he's like Chris is a [__] idiot I
don't know what's going on if Chris has
like Tommy's a [__] idiot I don't
know what's going on well because we're
both [__] idiots
they think they're both not idiots
that's the problem well there's an
overlay you gotta trick them
gotta keep these [__]
dude Tommy came in asking Tech questions
I was like what though they changed
rolls over there
Cameron look how beautiful this is this
is like uh you know
this is the goal there's something about
to go into dead up to your eyeballs yes
eventually welcome to the party boy yeah
I can't wait to get it's funny the
energy does change so much when we get a
couple of drinks in this she came in
very formal you were wandering around
the studio I was trying to get a check
Chris's Pockets
probably stealing his own merch
I brought that it says Tony's on it
he's picking up the merch from stuff
Island look over he's wearing the night
suit
which he would fit me can we get you in
there please man
we could put you in that that is you
it's a little greasy
it's very greasy she's a little too tall
he's like six one yeah yeah it's like a
saddle yeah it's big from up here though
oh Connor you would fit in that
perfectly there's no way I just want us
to cut and come back
not a [__] chance no it's like that
he's got the helmet on oh man
everything's all right crazy it's a real
suit of armor it's like that uh no it's
not
you think there was a knight in the
Middle Ages with the legs like that no
this is gonna end with someone getting
stabbed with a sword yeah first of all
that's a real sword yeah it's made out
of a 10 000 Bud Light cans
that's that's joust uh certified
medieval times
[Laughter]
look at the thighs dude yeah the thighs
aren't great but they were littler back
then dude he's got Homer Simpson yeah
dude it really does it's like [__]
it's for a little bald it's on a
mannequin thing in there you'd put that
on and be a little bit tighter no I it
needs to be looser dude I feel like look
at the hips
I mean we can get you in the top the top
would fit I'm in the top all right I'll
get in the top all right tell me the top
easy it would be nice to Adorn like some
chain mail you know it would be cool
back then in the spring yeah what do you
got a [__] Mouse in your pocket I I
just saw the table to be okay
I would probably think he's some sort of
God or something yeah
yeah you know like the beginning of
[__] uh Gladiator when there's that
like uh that German dude who's like yeah
and he's just swinging that thing and
just [__] I'd be like don't add the
Berserker yeah
[Laughter]
like when the elephant crushes in 300
just [__] them yeah I wouldn't I'd be
I'd I'd die anyway we're gonna try that
on after this
two weeks without my heartburn
medication
situation I think about that [__] all
the time man before air conditioning and
Refrigeration I don't give a [__] what's
going on I would not want to be around
for it oh dude I without Uber I'd be
dead
well also even like the turns they take
in the universe I know but at least they
get you home yeah dude I yelled at some
guy on a donkey the way I idiot the
other way I'm drinking the BQE
stop he's going the wrong way that's
[__] idiot you can't get good help
anymore stop that thing from [__]
dude the way I drink and the places I
choose to go when I'm drink ah there's
no way I would be a hail in a cab yeah
you've been a different country every
year yeah you'd wake up in a different
time period man knows 17 languages
that's because she's a drunk it gets
caught in a different complex he keeps
looking for after-hour spots
you start drinking you're just Chasing
the Sun
but he's putting a letter in a carrier
pigeon tell his family since Sudan now
it's happy hour all day
tell Mom
what is that all the carrier pigeons
died is that true
I think carrier pigeons are extinct oh
the actual species of carrier pigeons as
a breed I'm sure they're still banging I
don't know is it a breather they're all
over Queens
I kicked one on my way here they flip
them when the cops are coming what are
you talking about
they take their little uniform off oh
[__]
wait hold on I thought a carrier pigeon
was just a pigeon that was designed to
train to be I think he's messages no as
a certain breed of pigeons yeah and I
think they're extinct I think like
because they actually used to use them
to like say you know that and you're
right that's weird
the Benny's alone they wear Polo shirts
and a hard hat khakis different yeah I
got a beach house and Point Lookout Toby
what's the deal yeah 1914 the last known
passenger pigeon female name Martha died
of the Cincinnati Zoo damn sometimes
autism
and I tell you because I wanted one wait
why well and when well first it started
blow this down I mean there was a girl I
liked in school
she was trying
I mean you're like me too in the middle
of math class dude imagine if you had
access to roads Chris is that a pigeon
in your desk oh Connor's just looking
around tell me if you had the last
passenger pigeon imagine how much [__]
you'd be getting dude delivering I mean
my handwriting's terrible but
handwritten letters
[Laughter]
dear Stephanie I hope this letter finds
you well it's just a drawing of your
weird dick
you're inside shaped wiener How do they
work how do you communicate
Toby how do they know where to go I mean
the little ruin the podcast yes of
course now it's all right I want to know
now what I know but you have to just
guess because I've tried to look this up
and nobody gives you good they have to
have something on the other end like a
piece of bacon or something like that no
it's just like one of those things they
just love bacon yeah it's just one thing
I know about birds
they're throwing some pork seed out
there for the babies all right they take
they take the pigeon from its home and
they transport it to a spot they attach
a message to it and then it naturally
flies home yeah
so it's only a one-way call wait yeah
also you have to go to the place to the
whole point so you don't have to go to
where the thing needs to be see this is
what I'm saying the whole thing is
broken oh what do you guys think carrier
pigeons are outdated technology yeah
I'm saying it doesn't even make sense in
no yes it does totally no yes if you're
if it's the whatever the 18 I gotta
travel somewhere to send a message back
home that doesn't make any sense when
did they use them no you want you don't
have to travel to send the message
you're traveling and to send the message
oh it just go bird goes home oh so you
can only call home
here we go you steal the you steal the
bird knowing you got a long Trek and you
got some [__] to do you take the bird
with you so you can send postcards I
gotta go to the Grand Canyon I gotta get
Chris to the Grand Canyon let them know
I found the Grand Canyon I found it at
hey Chris found the Grand Canyon there
you go
for one puts it in the holster in case
he has to give me a message
call that's why they're [__] dead you
got to shoot them in the head yeah he's
got the dirt on you too he knows where
you're at this is a one puff Vape I got
this no use for this [__] Tommy's up
there drinking
what
I think if you're so okay so you're a
soldier in World War One French soldier
you move up to the line I'm an American
Soldier what the [__] you're talking
about I'm not being a frog for this you
move up through the lines and then you
see oh [__] the Germans are right there
send the [__] bird back let him know
hey
yeah
you got it probably summed it up perfect
let him know how do you establish home
where they have to be born in the place
well I'll I was saying like they do
still got a better breakdown they do
still exist thank you so I will Escobar
was used them when he was in jail in the
exactly Cathedral really yeah they've
seen Norcos
yeah they smuggled like cell phones and
SIM cards in prisons
[Laughter]
I was in it your dream is alive man you
can get this pigeon dude let's go let's
do it you should have it you should have
a coop of pigeons in your you've got the
backyard you can flip some pictures I'm
surprised you're not growing anything
out there but we did the last three
years four or five years okay well last
year someone came over and planted
things and it didn't Harvest them that
was last year yeah last year was kind of
yeah okay we let the Cucumbers get too
plump they went Bonzo everything we came
over from planting stuff my old roommate
yeah okay Tommy was like I want a fresh
garden and then no he wanted a fresh
card
cherry tomatoes they blossom to it a
wild amount to like you're you're
plucking a hundred every like two days
and you can't use it all unless you're
making it yeah yeah I'm doing them this
year don't cherry tomatoes yeah you
should yeah you got a new spot right
yeah where are you are you or do you
don't say one plan is enough one tomato
it depends on what Channel tomatoes
cucumbers
do cucumbers and a meatloaf plant
a mop stick platform
you a meatloaf guy yeah you have
something about this you should do that
and look at this you'd make a good meal
do you want to do a meatloaf next time
you come I would love to do that next
time they don't know wait yeah they do
what is Meatloaf it's a loaf of me how
do you know we're talking about an
existential
breakdowns it's hamburger meat in a
steak form not necessarily no it's it's
it's pork veal and hamburger with a
little bit of bread it's a meatball yeah
it's a big meal it's an Italian giant
it's a giant Italian meatball and a loaf
but they have separate uh glazes for it
oh your mom didn't make meatloaf growing
up
never throw a meatloaf at you uh lasagna
I just ate whatever was in front of me
dude I didn't listen to what it was all
right well thanks for coming
today I think I'm sure every meal was
chicken parm and egg noodles and then
occasions all right occasionally a pork
chop that was you know uncooked to a
tire yeah in edible yeah Michelin chop
yeah you know we forget tacos is that
what our moms were when our moms had us
they were young they they did of course
they did suck they did suck in the
kitchen they were loose in the hips
letting anybody goof in them at 21.
your second boyfriend
any guy with a 401k they're rolled by
they didn't know how to make [__] my mom
sucked when we started out she made a
good apple pie but that was it it took
her years to get the cutlets how drunk
are you I'm pretty drunk
what time's that spot begin
they were trying her best he goes off on
a big tangent she made a good one no I I
honestly don't think it was my mom's
fault really I think it was my dad was
the limiting factor because anytime she
tried to make something good Chuck is
this yeah yeah like give me this [__] I
want dry pork and I want chicken parm
and egg noodles so there was no
experimentation wait your dad was old
school like that yeah yeah egg noodle my
dad my dad doesn't like eating
strawberries because of the seeds
because it's gas
he's like
yeah
your dad eats a hot dog like a
typewriter
no
uh that brings up that is funny but I
don't understand it uh it's because he
doesn't want to he doesn't want to eat
it like a wiener foreign
[Laughter]
that was a that was trusty I know
worries catch some food in there
my beer is done
that beer is never being touched what
was it what what was the food
that was like Back Against The Wall
[__] [__]
deep to right field look at oh bullies
got it bringing it back
oh dude we talked about that we've been
talking about this what is the best
what if you can't grill a hot dog
obviously Grill in a hot dog is the best
way to make a hot dog what's your second
what's the Trashy way you make hot dogs
I don't know if I would I would go with
that by the way I don't cut it down in
the middle crisp it up both sides
that's weird oh no Grill like no Grill
oh so you're in that you're in the
kitchen first of all let me tell you sir
you can boil it you can microwave it you
can put it on a pan okay if you're
slicing hot dogs
right out of the fridge you need a cold
I almost called 9-1-1 I thought he was
gonna get salmonella
if you're not throwing those to the
other side of the [__] Starbucks here
in that line
someone's just in the car like
oh my God
oh Connor was up against the road
depression there for a little while but
now he's coming back
foreign
[Laughter]
I want to establish something before we
get started the cutting down the middle
and all that [__] that stuff is lame
I like they're not talking about it I
need some we have some Flair on it ain't
bad yeah no it Heats it heats the middle
it heats the middle quicker dude and the
juice is sitting the trench no okay
everybody
what did your eyebrow
says
very frustrated Tommy's eyebrows with
the weather big fan of them that's how
the hot dog should look the way one time
Tommy give me a hot dog
this is the real name
okay let's talk about blue shoe knock
knock who's there my boner talk about a
product I can get behind baby not only a
spokesman [__] client right here you
should be the president I got a handful
of those things sitting next to the bed
I'll tell you that right I do them just
to pee sometimes gang we're not all
young men anymore you need a little help
you know what I'm saying if you had a
sore knee you're throwing knee brace on
it if the Johnson's not working get
yourself some Bluetooth I know be up
there standing at attention saluting the
flag yeah uh Bluetooth is a unique
online service that delivers chewable Ed
medicine right to your door to increase
performance and discreet and confidants
with the same active ingredients as
Viagra see Alice and Levitra but only at
a fraction of the call she'll be ready
to go whenever the opportunity arises
it's easy sign up at bluetooth.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers and you and once
you're approved you'll get prescription
you'll get your prescription in just
days Bluetooth tablets are made in the
U.S of a baby
chip to you is a degree packaging as the
as the big man said you're neighbor
won't know you got Ed unless you want it
though and they won't after you put it
in they'll be able to hear it too
Bluetooth wants you to help have better
sex discover your options at
bluetooth.com chew it into a baby and
we're gonna need a new headboard though
okay that's something bad and hopefully
we got a special deal for our listeners
try Bluetooth free when use our promo
code garbage at checkout just pay five
bucks for shipping right to your door
that's bluetooth.com promo code garbage
to receive your first month free baby
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information we thank
Bluetooth for sponsoring the podcast
baby now back to the shower back to the
show no I'm a big fan of the slice what
there's no juice you're not you're not
missing out it's just nitrate you're
telling me your mom was was slicing the
hot dog you're saying he likes doing
that now that's crazy what your mom did
and what you can do now as a 56 year old
man yeah
still like a personal attack on me or me
I mean he's got them on both sides no
the slicing I like the more I like
jarring on both sides as the grill is
the only option then I Char the bun on
both sides as well for texture okay say
it's 3am you're at the house you got
nothing in the fridge yeah you're not
doing it I got you are you doing the
same thing what about the fork through
the middle of the window just let me
[__] answer wait let's make a roll
you never like pat down the middle of
the break if you don't have rolls no you
take a fork let's hear from the guy
who's never cooked it once in his life
wait hold on we're wrong
I mean put a pit in your eyebrows
what are you talking about in order to
make a roll out of a slice of bread when
you don't have rolls is bend it no no no
no no no because it might you know if
you've got shitty bread in my crack what
you do what are you using no he's not
he's not so what you do is you take a
fork and you and you press down the
middle so you make like a little pocket
it's a little harder to make a hinge
yeah and then you roll it over
that's how we did it so you're telling
me you got the piece of bread
yeah
my culture's not your comedy
man you are a different level who was
doing that your parents oh yeah I mean
it's well established that his family
you put the tell me where did you go
kick the [__] out of Luke for not being
Johnny on the spot he's out there
beating Luke
wow
try it out it's good someone listening
to do that before that or my dad is a
technical genius he is an engineer
he may have come up with it where did
you go I had to touch up my zit are you
serious no I'm not [__] serious are
you talking about the one right here the
one right here [__]
oh big man coming in with a hand
that's when you thought he was down and
out
this is what you do okay so we're back
yeah you're you'll only have your and
you got to think you got a toaster yes
you got an air fryer yes you got a
frying pan and a microwave and you can
boil it if you want here's the basics
you want to you want to replicate the
reason I started with the the Char
grilling aspect I want to tell you that
the the optimal which I'm out um by the
way I don't I don't already hurt any of
this I already heard so you want what
about the what about this Italians and
they're complicated what about the
diagonals
I'll die I'll go spot I'll do that I
want to feel fancy that's not a hot dog
and nobody does that that's a hot dog no
first of all my Uncle Sam was doing it
back in the day first time ever saw it
shout out to him
I had a babysitter one time I had a
babysitter one really made the party
yeah yeah
I had a babysitter one time slice it
down the middle I'm waiting for you to
finish
oh you want to answer a question about
grilling nobody's talking about grilling
we're talking about himself
I'm feeling a bear I'm fearing a bear
hug [__] corporate takeover I've been
watching succession all week you're fine
I'll start the sentence over for the
fifth [__] time okay I started with
the whiskey Tommy's here
situation tell me there's no Grill
shut the [__] up foreign
he's talking about a cast iron skillet
you're wasting our time if you're gonna
be talking about grilling the reason I'm
talking are you boiling it or are you
cooking it in the pan
are you taking it are you taking a
lighter and just going back and forth on
it yeah
I've been in the hotel room jammed up
I'll tell you that
dude imagine the maid calling the SWAT
team with the lights
on the third floor cooking a hot dog sir
uh have you been smoking in here not
exactly
so the grilling thing is like you Char
both sides of the the dog and the bun
for texture that's optimal right to
duplicate that in just the kitchen if
you use cast iron as optimal and you put
weight on top I have like a little
weight thing you can put on yeah or you
could put a pan just put another pan on
top of the dog because when you slice it
it curls the ends so if you can flatten
that with another pan on top of a a
larger pan it'll keep it flat and
cooking at a high temperature to
caramelize this is all European [__]
that's not the way
yeah you don't slice European French
culinary school you don't slice it all
right that's fine yeah Henry why are you
dying on this hill what are you talking
about hot dogs this is all he's got to
live here man you ever cut him open
you've never watched 17 fly yet
this guy's mostly dogs
hot dogs and license plates they're all
undercooked they're all these tiger
sharks are pretty wild
if Jaws is a land shark
then you take the bun and put it in the
toaster because it'll evenly crisp on
both sides so the crisping on the inside
is to keep from the moisture uh
overtaking see I like inside
the outside yeah the texture is the
crunch right people don't think to to
cook the outside of like a burger bun
but you get the crunch they cook the
inside so it doesn't over saturate with
moisture and make it soft and chewy okay
well yeah enough for sure cooking a hot
dog in a hotel room with a lighter is
fine
they did a job didn't it
was able to pass out 20 minutes later
right
[Applause]
the beat the beat I don't like him cut
you know what's crazy is I hear stuff
like that and it's and it's like
depraved as it is I still admire the
ambition the get up and go why not just
eat it cold because you're not a
psychopath yeah and you are but burning
watching Seinfeld and burning a hot dog
for 15 minutes with a Bic lighter is
more sane than just eating a cold hot
dog
bites yes
yeah dude I gotta get you a blow to it
all right so all right let's then go you
what do you think pans out right the pan
or you do the pan but now what's The
Next Step At what point are you planted
in a microwave I think you just divorce
your wife leave your kids back up and go
move on Tommy's not eating hot dogs like
that at the house once he once or twice
a year and it's usually so the episode
we're gonna do I was thinking about
doing a Memorial Day episode right to
kick off summer so we could either do it
I was eating them on the grill like a
gentleman I was thinking doing skirt
steak tacos I'll make some uh two taco
sauce American tacos
disrespect
I'm not doing chimichurri sauce
well that's why I'm gonna have a bowl of
raw hot dogs for you
Grill lighters
[Laughter]
just cooking hot dogs one by one yeah
yeah America boys
sending them to key Foods get more hot
dogs
find your way home boys find your way
home
because I grew up I grew up on my own
having to I would microwave them admire
cheese dogs are nice in the microwave a
minute and I throw them on some Martin's
potato rolls we boiled we boiled the
heavy boiling yeah we were boiling I go
microwave before boil yeah right
did you ever do that you ever heard this
trick oh no my mind was blown my aunt
was taking us to the beach she boiled
the hot dogs in a Wildwood motel room
where I like to [__] see some
seashell motel or whatever baby and then
took the hot water and the hot dogs and
put it in like a six-pack cooler and
brought that to the beach so you opened
it up and had hot hot dogs right on the
[__] piece [__] it blew my life does
America have a queen that is if it
doesn't take care oh my God yeah that's
when they're at their best right out of
the hot water poorly made Oh I thought
you meant ants
with eight bucks yeah dude that that's
that's what it was she had to feed
[__] 14 seconds yeah that's like
that's up there with engineering wise
with like Apollo 13 and I come up with
like that that way to convert
this circle in this square with these
things yeah how do we keep these hot
dogs hot we can use the cooler what
how do you make it cooler Neighbors at
the motel we're like that ain't gonna
work first of all first of all right
it's just Madness that's gonna kill
everybody on that beat that cool Mom's
up there on the chalkboard like we need
to get these hot dogs from here
[Laughter]
everyone's got high in Tights they're
smoking cigarettes
and Harris is there for some reason
every sleeves are rolled up
I'm not gonna let these Americans die on
my watch I'm not gonna let this fat kid
starve on Fourth of July weekend in
Wildwood now listen to me listen to me
right now that fat piece of shit's gonna
be done body surfing about five minutes
and he better have a goddamn hot dog in
his mouth if he takes a bite and 200
guys stand up yeah
I don't complain
dude I imagine there's like 400 coolers
and ain't Karen's backyard because she
can only you can only travel with hot
dog water once without throwing that out
this is going to be a disaster actually
I think it's gonna be our finest hour
I'll never forget I remember being then
I was like oh we're trashy like even
that it was like it was great and it
blew my mind but it was one of those
moments that forever stuck with me of
man we're caught from a little bit of a
Different Cloth because I've never seen
this before yeah no one's rolling with
[__] a cooler full of diesel yeah but
when you're 13 you're like the shake is
[__] yeah she was a shout out there
she was a brilliant woman yeah
yeah
all right let's get this thing started
right there question number one if you
were to cook a hot dog
because uh another thing too sorry we've
been talking diesels of hot dogs a lot
but was the hot dog roller my boy Pat's
family had a hot dog roller and for
parties in the summer you go over they
have like a pool whatever you're hanging
they would do like a big crab thing or
whatever but they'd always have a hot
dog roller with like just 30 dogs going
at all times
[__] up you just walk over throw one
on Stave off
I thought you meant it was like a joint
roller yeah
you thought we were tubing them the
trick is you buy the baloney and then
you just roll it
no that's actually that's a brilliant
move because people like growing up you
would think a hot dog roller you'd have
to like invest in the 7-Eleven sure
you're gonna be here tomorrow I swear to
God I just bought one to this day when I
see the grease on a 7-Eleven hot dog
roller salivated something about it's
all it's there's a great snap on a hot
dog roller yeah if they really took some
some care some love into that hot dog
roller you gotta be consultant for this
they really could they could make some
magic over there they really could they
just they don't try they don't man
they're just standing back there jerking
each other
earnestly goes
they're hiring a security guard every
day that is you are straight on the
downhill into old age when you're like
they they don't even try over there I'll
tell you this it's like a place where
they're fighting for their life have you
tried their seven-year-old apple pie
dude every shift they gotta attack
someone with a broom I'll tell you this
this is your job you ever had a weave in
your hot dog 7-Eleven if you're if
you're watching
get rid of the taquitos focus and put
some goddamn effort into it you'll be
all right the ketos their chili sauce is
great and their cheese ain't bad you
have the 7-Eleven pretzel
pretty [__] good oh they've always
had a solid press it's better than Wawa
Wawa used to have good ones 15 years ago
they fell the [__] off 7-Eleven props
finally trying to get you yeah and I get
it every time they undercooked the
middle yeah they went they went downhill
years ago but 7-Eleven still got a
[__] uh hot it's a heater dude a soft
pretzel Ah that's not true okay here we
go here's why they truly everybody I
caught myself
that's what that cough was earlier
oh yeah I caught one the other day
you cough up the keys to a 7-Eleven
I forgot that when my dad passed away
everybody brought the uh the Philly the
Pretzel was that the company Philly Soft
Pretzel yeah yeah it's a little trays
they're [__] great dude that with the
cheese they have the cinnamon the
cinnamon first thing I do when it's a
buffalo too I think when I get this 30
Street Station first thing I do I got
one in there Philly Pretzel Factory
that's the first person I had a pretzel
hot dog like that hot dog I knew I was
fat I was sitting on a bench waiting to
get a train back to the suburbs eating a
double a double hot dog pretzel box that
just [__] in your pants just grease I
remember being like I got him exchange
sitting on a cooler Hot Dog Water dude
that lit my dad's world on fire oh the
hot dog pretzel no it went just the
pretzel the pretzel sauce pretzel with
the like yellow mustard he was like it
was the first time he had one yeah he
was like holy [__] yes sir yeah well
back in the day they used to sell them
on the corners yeah there was the
pretzel guys yeah people were bad they
don't understand like in our minivan she
trucked them over the hood over the
windshield all under the roof and fell
off the side it would have even in
Byberry dude yes what the hell happened
it was his fault
these bullet pretzels off them because
my fat ass was in the back seat and
wanted pretzels and she thought it was a
drive-through
Guys Smoke him too it's so funny just
burying the pretzel guy and turn around
be like free pretzels kids I never get
your fat ass out there and get the
pretzels coming in through the sunroom
yeah she just mulched him he she went
one way and then went over and she
pressed the light change someone hung I
mean hey you you play with fire you're
gonna get burned you're selling pretzels
in traffic dude people don't realize
like the pretzels were like such a
staple where grade school you'd have a
salt pretzel snack time with juice sure
at lunch you'd have bagged hard pretzels
and then at home that was your snack
after dinner you would eat cream cheese
and pretzels yeah I had pretzels three
meals a day for like 20 years oh that's
all it was that's all it was yeah dude I
was weaning off a pretzel when I went to
college I was like dude how do I get a
pretzel did I call what pyramid
pretzels a day yeah the whole bottom
chunk is practically brought into that
food pyramid yeah dude I remember eating
I eating toast going that's only four
servings yeah
I'm halfway there that's why everybody's
built like an upside down pyramid
it's just all you know
oh look at this big man more bread at
table three please
Foley's blocking every single angle
there's nobody in shot right now no I'm
still gold I'm gone
Foley's in phase
even with the goods Dad this is the
first I mean I think we're like 300 some
episodes this is the first like proper
drinking non-patreon episode we've had
let's go oh cheers yeah well we did the
uh the New Year's live stream which I
mean that was a problem oh my God that
was a proper that was fun oh Connor
wasn't there that's why it was fun it
was Finding himself I'm kidding Chris
I miss you baby
[Laughter]
oh Connie I'll take a uh
white cloth yes thank you what time of
the day is it I don't know five
thanks pal what time is it hey Siri I
want to pee real quick uh all right
let's see let's do some questions guys
as you know when you join the patreon we
will answer your garbage questions on
the air it's just the best way to do it
Hachi Machi this one's from Alex what
was the term y'all use for High Grade
weed growing up ah we used to say dank
yeah dank was bad dank was big that was
the first one dank dank nuggets I think
we were kind bud I remember when kind
bud started it was it was regular brick
weed before that and then people started
growing it or we started getting our
hands on it and it was called kind bud
my roommate used to say the heady
goodness heady heady was good this is
real heady did you punch him in the face
I hope you did did you pull his lanyard
off his belt slap it back
no no
spaghetti uh alcohol
okay any questions
uh this one's just funny this was from
Thomas have you ever kissed a fish
yes you caught a fish and kissed it I
have I used to kiss we had a red tail
shark as a kid what it was actually my
brother wait a minute wait it's a red
tail shark is not an actual shark it's
just a little fish with a red tail but
yeah yeah
you had to change the water and I'd give
him a kiss oh that's pretty cool that's
all right that's cute are you a big fish
tank kid growing up uh they're very nice
my brother had a fish tank and I was
like yeah this is cool you have it in
his room yeah they're nice to go to bed
with yeah like yeah I wish I wish not
after dinner no no I wish fish tanks
didn't become like the ultimate weird
it's up there with like a sword on your
wall it became a strange thing like it
is yeah yeah or a night a full full
armor yeah
we don't know what you're talking about
no because all the chicks dig it dude
remember the fish tank we saw in
Poughkeepsie
yeah it's a bar yeah it's fantastic it
was at a bar very tranquil but if you
walk into someone's house it and you
don't know they have a fish tank you
walk in and you flick the lights and
there's a fish tank you go ah looking a
little different yeah it's a little
different yeah and it's like only get
normal fish don't get exotic fish I mean
tropical if you get salt salt water is a
pain in the ass
is that what you mean I just mean what's
a normal fish I don't know [__]
retail shark yeah yeah you got a sunny
in there there's stuff just stuff that
you I don't know if you put too much
time in your fish if you're buying
expensive fish you're a psychopath I
think your psycho just having a tank
yeah it's a lot and they smell if you
don't you got to stay on them yeah for
kids that don't have friends and you're
like you're fine just pick a name for
each yeah name each one and give them a
backstory yeah so then when they die
we'll replace them when you're at school
yeah you know would you get a lava lamp
no I was never allowed because my mom
would yell that's a fire hazard I also
that's dank the lava lamp is a pure sign
I had one in high school
so what of it
in high school yeah in high school oh my
God you're [__] wealthy dude you talk
so much [__] what are you talking about
ground pool and a waterbed
billionaire that's insane no one's
bringing this up yeah that's crazy money
dude yeah no I think they're it's trash
it's crazy no it's because it's his
parents didn't go out and buy him a new
water I got it for free yeah that's the
thing he's jerking off causing a tsunami
by the way what neighborhood kids had to
seek shelter yeah brother got it for
free I can't remember exactly how we got
it I think someone just gave you a bag
my aunt and uncle got into the waterbed
scene
they were swingers
word of God's shame in the late 80s they
got into it and then they got one that
had the mattress topper on it where it
was like kind of it was a little it
densened it a little bit and I got their
old one and you know what's funny not
until this second that I realized they
were probably banging in that water bed
and I slept in it yeah oh yeah dude has
a waterbed and doesn't bang and he put
shout out from Uncle Mike closing deals
also I [__] on a water bed seems like
a night that's what I said but people
that said people that have done it have
been like no it's great it seemed I
don't know how to get any left now no
it's also not only that but it's like
matching your rhythm with the girl is
hard enough
tied in there you're [__] do you stop
you know if it's not going well do you
stop and fill it up it's always not
going well
so they had a water bed and my my mother
father would drop me off just to like
sleep remember when they got it you went
over and saw it you went over and looked
at it it was great but they'd feed me
Peeps and [__] uh the
chocolate-filled bunnies or peanut
butter-filled bunnies sure the Reese's
John's yeah no not really
catch you around are the yellow ones no
yeah no no hold on it does matter
because that's weird no no why did they
have peeps in the house all year round
we were jumping on a waterbed eating
pizza chocolate covered that's the point
it was my [__] jungle gym so my
parents were like you could stay over
anyway stay over I get up at like eight
you know wait go to wake up them and
their [__] ass nude on this
watermelon never forget oh just seeing
Aunt Mimi's tits like in her side pocket
and Uncle Neil [__] he was a Vietnam
vet just asked nude as well like they
just got done and there's like six
nephews and nieces in different bedrooms
and they're just raw dog free dog let me
tell you something nope nothing because
they got married at 21. there's just
nothing more scarring than a young child
watching adults sleep ah it's nude it's
anything I I remember just being a
little kid watching like my Aunt sleep
watching my dad sleep and just being
like what the [__] this is my future
wild yeah powered down yeah you seem
like the creep in this story I'm not
gonna lie yeah I was watching on my
auntie and watching my daddy I would I
would sure I feel like my dad was asleep
I was like thank [__] Chris dude I
was [__] yeah yeah I finally lowered
my shoulders a little bit [__] whack
I'm not gonna wake this week yeah yeah
yeah I'm outside dude you had 20 minutes
of like this is a trap this is a trap
yeah if I get close he's gonna grab me
he's just trying to lure me in
all right we gotta wrap it up gang holy
[__] what a time
going here Toby I'm going I'm going
close up or go super single or I go wide
whatever you want see isn't this great
gang we love you to death stuff Island
Boys you're on tour it's not like we
just chose not to do this
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what this is like it's like
when there's like a high school kid that
like wants to go to college and your
father takes around the college and you
put your feet on like Turf and you're
like I want to be here
this [__] fake carpet I'm like I want
to pee on this fake card
to local 2287 of boys thank you well
side work for them
whoa that's why I didn't say their names
because they got side works exactly they
bought weeds
non-union I bet no I paid very well
um
he was like I'll use you
where's my camera Toby where am I at
Toby hit me and we're all union workers
just side work gang the stuff island
boys were here boys are on tour uh we're
just getting done yeah
thanks for inviting us first but we
gotta follow your good friends Bert
Kreischer over three months ago hey you
do 400 000 views and you can come back
shout out to the machine come on guys
hit that like
buttons the machine is going to be in
Cedars May 26th by the way make sure you
check that the [__] out you tell me who
is more fun
I'll tell you it was weirder
this guy [__] Mr meatloaf over here
yeah but did you guys spend 45 minutes
on hot dog cooking
let's go what do you got
uh May 26th dude all right Toby cam
oh Connor's Truck Yeah
sorry May 26 we're at uh we're in Rhode
Island Newport Rhode Island at the Rhode
Island Comedy Festival now we're set
we're going to set up a little fall tour
I hear that's nice that Rhode Island
yeah yeah it's up there in Newport yeah
yeah you can you can get promo code
stuff if you buy tickets to that with
the promo code stuff you get like 20 off
or something like that go see the boys
everybody
else in the whole world we [__] love
you I love you too man we're on the road
obviously we're on the road we're all
over the place uh we got Cleveland
Columbus and Louisville left on this leg
we're uh we got the suits tying up the
the next leg of the tour that should be
being announced soon we got merch
available over at rugarbage.com and join
the [__] patreon shout out to you as
we love you gang we love you to death
peace thanks buddy